it's been nearly 50 years since Bruce
Lee died suddenly in the prime of his
life but his legend lives on her ways
that even he could never have imagined
here's a look at the highlights and
lowlights of his long and buried career
from the movies that made him an icon to
the ones we'd rather just forget Game of
Death was a movie famously built around
the footage Bruce Lee left behind from
his unfinished final film most of which
consisted of fight scenes that took
place on various levels of a pagoda
after Lee's death Enter the Dragon
director Robert Klaus took that footage
and integrated it into a new story about
a martial arts movie star being hunted
by a crime syndicate
Game of Death is also notorious for
integrating footage of Lee from his
other movies often to jarring effect and
at one point even uses footage of Lee's
actual body in his casket if Game of
Death had simply been made as a 70s
martial-arts flick pull-up subterfuge
and slick fight scenes it wouldn't be a
bad movie at all as it is the footage
that doesn't try to trick you into
thinking you're watching Bruce Lee a
solid the opening credits are killer and
John Barry's score is probably the best
thing about it watching it in context as
a film cobbled together from Lee's
unfinished work however makes it a
trying viewing experience and a sad
reminder of what might have been the
game of death was supposed to star Bruce
Lee as a retired martial artist who's
coerced into retrieving something
valuable from the top of a mysterious
pagoda with each level guarded by a
martial artist with a different fighting
style as you know however the true
version of the movie never came to
fruition thanks to Lee's untimely
passing what footage did exist was later
released as part of the documentary
Bruce Lee a warrior's journey the game
of deaths climax featured Lee and his
now iconic yellow tracksuit taking on
these martial artists in a series of
precisely choreographed battles
culminating in a fight scene with Kareem
abdul-jabbar's character at the pagoda
summit watching what exists of The Game
of Death is a bittersweet experience
because while we'll never get to see the
full film seeing what Lee was able to do
with this level of creative control and
precision is truly astonishing
nonetheless Bruce Lee's first major
introduction to American audiences was
as Kato in the Green Hornet the
superhero action-adventure series in
which he stole the show is sidekick to
the titular masked hero the show was
successful in America but overseas it
made Lee and even
bigger star to the point that in Hong
Kong it became known as the Kato show
lease international popularity is Catoe
combined with the mythology that sprung
up around named after his untimely death
in 1973 led Fox to consider repurposing
the old Green Hornet episodes to
capitalize on a Spain so in 1974 they
cut together several episodes from the
1966-67 series and released them as a
feature film it did well in some markets
but as you might expect from a heavily
episodic series like the Green Hornet
it doesn't actually work all that well
as a movie with a narrative through line
the way of the Dragon is the first film
in which Bruce Lee officially stepped
into the role of both director and
screenwriter giving him more creative
control than he'd had on any of his
previous works the story is relatively
simple a martial artist heads to a
foreign land to become an enforcer in a
fight to save innocent people from a
tyrannical crime boss however more than
any of his previous films this one is
truly infused with Lee's personality's
sense of humor and sense of pacing
because of that way of the Dragon is
funnier than Lee's previous Hong Kong
films as he plays the fish-out-of-water
with a huge amount of fun it's also got
a more ambitious sense of action as
exemplified by the scenes in which he
single-handedly takes on a gang of thugs
inside the restaurant at the center of
the conflict most famously though this
is the film in which Bruce Lee fights
Chuck Norris who made his big-screen
debut with Way of the Dragon
that bite which is set inside Rome's
Coliseum still holds up is one of the
coolest things to have ever happened in
martial arts cinema
[Music]
Bruce Lee's first major leading role in
a martial arts film was the big boss the
film he made after returning to Hong
Kong following a short and frustrating
an attempt to break Hollywood Lee plays
Cheng Chao an a young man who moves from
China to Thailand to live with family
members who are unknowingly connected to
a drug smuggling ring run out of an ice
factory things start to get rough almost
immediately but Chang can't join the
fight because of a promise he made to
his mother to never get involved in
violence let's be clear the big boss is
actually a pretty good movie it just
happens to be the worst of the major
martial arts films that Lee had
completed at the time of his death there
are some terrific fight scenes here and
Lee's on-screen swagger is palpable when
viewed alongside his later work though
you can easily see just how much further
he could really push himself sadly it's
impossible to separate the release of
Enter the Dragon from the death of its
star Bruce Lee died just weeks before
this film was released in America and
while it was supposed to make him a
global star by bringing his Hollywood
kung fu stylings to a bigger audience in
death it made him an icon Enter the
Dragon remains one of the most
culturally significant films of the
1970s a watershed moment that informed
and influenced countless martial arts
films that came after as well as action
cinema in general even when you try to
see the film outside the context of
Lee's death you'll still experience a
masterpiece Enter the Dragon is the work
of a young star who poured everything
he'd learned from his past hits into
this one perfection seeking mega hit it
remains a riveting film from Lee's
emotional content speech near the
beginning all the way to that legendary
mirrored room fight scene at the end
what was that an exhibition we emotional
content check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]